for america's fossil fuel lobby this is
a major prize they've robbed president
biden of his main tool for cutting
carbon emissions from u.s power plants
the supreme court ruled 6-3 against the
u.s environmental protection agency not
stripping it of pollution controlling
powers but preventing them being used
against an entire fuel type
conservative lobbyists are delighted
what it did say was that the the epa did
not have the power to destroy the coal
industry for something as politically
and economically significant as that it
needs clear direction from congress and
certainly that direction has not been
given
a total of 18 states and two coal mining
companies joined west virginia in
bringing this action many are top coal
producing states and no surprise nearly
all of them are republican-led and it
matters because over half of u.s
electricity is generated by fossil fuels
mainly coal and gas so it's a major
setback for joe biden's 2050 net zero
target but not a complete loss firstly
look here at coal even through the trump
era coal use was coming steadily down
through the early since the early 2000s
and today's ruling doesn't diminish
individual states authority to regulate
emissions there are 21 states with net
zero targets of their own and their own
rules to close coal and gas power plants
based on sure economics we're seeing
coal becoming increasingly uneconomic
and renewable energy battery storage are
becoming cheaper by the day and there's
a big uptake but it's not happening fast
enough not on the scale necessary and
federal action is critical to securing
the scale of that progress as quickly as
we need it
today's victory was secured in part by
donald trump who as well as digging coal
loaded the supreme court with
conservative judges
despite their best efforts fossil fuels
are on the way out question is will
today's ruling prevent them from going
fast enough to prevent dangerous climate
change
tom clark sky news